I owe about 70k in loans and I'm just
Ian I stress every day about it when I
wake up so I'm just trying to see you
guys' view on how I should start
attacking my loan 32k in a one semester
of student loans I'm not very proud of
this one but I actually 36k on a car law
and then I have a personal loan for like
3700 okay and how much are you making my
base salary is 24,000 and I make maybe a
thousand a month in commission your car
loan is what you make a year
yeah so we got to figure out a plan to
get that to get that out of your life
the mad at you hear is that that the
systems that surround an 18 to 19
yearold allowed you a kid just trying to
do what everyone's telling you to do you
got to go get a nice car you got to get
a good sales job you got to go to this
college that cost 30 $4,000 or whatever
it was a semester you got to go do this
stuff and you can't afford it